cómo
economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar en la
región de américa latina chile y el plan
de retiro de una tercera fracción de los
de las pensiones santiago muy buenas
noches pues el presidente sebastián
piñera anunció que va a promulgar esta
ley apenas horas después de que el
tribunal constitucional rechazara un
requerimiento suyo para tratar de frenar
la iniciativa a pesar de que había
contado con una abrumadora mayoría en el
congreso el presidente cedió a la
presión popular y de algunos
congresistas oficialistas con la
eventual promulgación la ley quedaría de
la siguiente manera se permite un tercer
retiro del 10% de los ahorros que tengan
todos los afiliados a los fondos
privados el mínimo es un millón de pesos
chilenos es decir unos 1.400 dólares al
cambio de hoy y el máximo de lo que
equivale a unos 6 mil 100 dólares estará
exento este retiro de impuestos y no es
obligatorio hacer reintegros o lo que sí
es opcional es que quienes saquen sus
ahorros cotizan una parte adicional por
un año para recuperarlos hablemos ahora
de los contratistas federales
sonidos que van a recibir un aumento en
sus salarios esto por supuesto
estimulará la economía
-claro santiago puede ser recordemos que
subir el mínimo fue lo que trató de
hacer el presidente joe biden dentro de
su plan de estímulos pero el congreso le
dijo no ahora el mandatario decidió
unilateralmente a hacerlo con
contratistas federales que van desde
profesionales de la limpieza y
trabajadores de mantenimiento hasta
asistentes de enfermería son alrededor
de 300 no que hoy ganan unos 10 95
dólares por hora la orden ejecutiva
aumentará el salario mínimo por hora
para los contratistas federales a 15
dólares en contratos nuevos renovaciones
y opciones de contrato a partir de enero
de 2022 y debe implementarse antes del
30 de marzo de 2022 para continuar
interesando el salario mínimo a la
inflación hablemos ahora de europa
daniela porque francia de alemania
presentaron sus respectivos planes de
recuperación económica por la pandemia
de kobe 19 como lo suele santiago el
fondo de recuperación europea tiene 750
mil millones de euros para repartir
entre los 27 miembros de la
a partir de junio próximo cada país debe
presentar un plan sobre cómo los van a
utilizar
italia ya presentó el suyo y ahora lo
someterá a aprobación francia por 40 mil
millones de euros y alemán jan por 25
mil millones de euros aunque la comisión
europea es la que tiene la última
palabra pero todos tienen algo en común
escuchemos que es cuyas sean de auto y
que les estamos enviando una señal clara
a favor de un sueldo amigable con el
clima el 90 por ciento del gasto del
plan de alemán está dirigido a la acción
climática de la transformación digital
transformation hoy se comparte el punto
de vista expresado por la fe y la lucha
contra el cambio climático es claramente
el desafío para todos los países
europeos para las próximas décadas
gates hablemos ahora de los compositores
de grandes artistas a nivel
internacional que se rebelaron por sus
salarios les pagan muy poco al parecer
si santiago porque mire la campaña la
lidera la británica dee hay bolsa karem
y la misma que hace una semana
justamente habló en nombre de
reconocidos artistas para quejarse por
el mal pago que reciben ellos de los
servicios
ahora más de 2000 compositores y
artistas entre los que se encuentran
actores autores de mejor de temas que
han interpretado artistas como shakira
dual y para exámenes o calvin harris
entre otros pidieron a las discográficas
una remuneración más justa calculan que
cada compositor que esté trabajando en
un proyecto con un cantante debe recibir
unos 120 dólares diarios como mínimo uno
de ellos es autor
robbie quien ha escrito canciones para
dual y para quien dice que está en un
punto en el que prefiere no escribir en
lo absoluto pues están normalizando que
los autores escriben gratis para un
artista esperando qué va a suceder en un
par de años agrega que no puede seguir
pagando para desarrollar marcas de otras
personas en las que no tiene ningún
interés personal hablemos ahora de los
indicadores como él es para los
principales parqués a nivel mundial
santiago wall street cerró plano porque
todos los inversionistas están a la
espera de que termine la reunión de dos
días de la reserva federal este
miércoles en europa tampoco hubo
movimientos muy bruscos allí el mercado
también tiene los ojos puestos sobre él
resultados empresariales y en américa
latina hubo un alza notable en la bolsa
de buenos aires de más del 2 por ciento
la cifra nítida para el cierre 4.2
billones de dólares que se espera que
gasten en la red
los compradores globales este año un 20
más 20 por ciento más que en 2020 esto
según adobe que recopila datos de
transacciones directas en 80 países
muchas gracias daniela es todo por el
momento aquí en france 24 siga con
nuestra programación buenas noches para
todos
[Música]